[Music]
[Music]
here in this video we will take a look
at the 10 different alien species that
are seen and described in the predator
extended universe which means avp and
comics universe as well
so let's get to it
firstly the yoja
let's start with the predators
themselves they are from a planet called
the alger prime and are a warrior
species that loves to hunt and battle
most of them are around 7 feet tall
while some of them are over 11
and the feral is just 2 meters tall or
maybe 6.9 feet tall as some have pointed
out they are humanoid in body shape with
two hands and legs
their heads are bigger than humans and
appear to be bulbous with dreadlocks
like outgrowths on the back of their
skulls they have scaly reptilian skin
with quilts growing out of theirs
certain parts of them their eyes are
situated in a hollow socket in their
skulls and they have a deadly smile with
four mandibles that open up wide with a
set of teeth on the inner mouth they are
also very
highly technologically advanced compared
to humans
second the quads are rich not much is
known about this strange alien creature
that inhabits the same planet as the
predators but can be infer that they are
not sentient or maybe semi-sentient
species
as we have said yautja prime the
homeworld of the predators is the
habitat of this same alien species they
are regarded as one of the yautja
prime's toughest native species
young predators unblooded always hunt in
groups of trees as per customs they are
sent out in groups and to be recognized
as an adult
clan members they must kill a single
quadzera ridge together
thirdly we have the drew kathy
these are an ancient alien race and are
called the dukrathi and they inhabited
the milky way galaxy way back in the
past despite the fact that the dukati
had gone on and were no longer present
in the galaxy they possessed incredibly
strong technology that even the yavjas
feared
they had two thinner arms and four
robust legs on six limbs
they had recognizable cannon features or
dog-like features especially in the way
their skulls were shaped they are said
to be very large standing around 12 feet
tall
fourthly we have the amengi these are an
alien species that ruled over and
enslaved the predators when the yavjas
were a more primitive bunch
when their own planet resources were
depleted these insectoid alien rays
would attack other planets to take over
their resources and enslave the
inhabitants such was the case for the
yautjas they are an insectoid rays that
resemble man-sized cockroaches with
different technological gadgets attached
to them other wings are clipped when
they are young and the skulls have two
lobes
they have two sets of rear legs and two
sets of a opposable hook arms giving
them a total of six limbs
confusing right yeah even i am
next we have the engineers also known as
the pilots or the space jockeys these
aliens are one of the most advanced and
powerful ones from the extended universe
the engineers are regarded as one of the
most dangerous creatures a predator
would encounter and are usually avoided
by them altogether but in certain
occasions like in the instance of ahab
he would undertake a challenge to take
one down
and he eventually did it with the help
of a human although losing the function
of his right or maybe his left arm one
of his one of his arms the engineers are
large human-like aliens and measure
between 8 to 14 feet tall they also have
an exoskeleton-like powered suit with a
helmet that looks like an elephant trunk
they are believed to be the ones who
created the xenomorphs and even humans
by their work
the sixth alien species here on this
list are the xenomorphs of course most
of us know what these aliens are the
xenomorphs are one of the deadliest
creatures in any universe let's just say
that
the deadliest and the scariest as well
these aliens are dark to black in
coloration they are quadrupedal but can
stand on two feet they have a prehensile
tail with sharp spear-like tips at the
end their entire body is encased in a
tough exoskeleton and their heads are
elongated and also bulbous
they are fast healthy agile hostile to
all life and they bleed acidic blood
their life cycle follows several stages
from egg to facehugger to chest burster
to an adult or drone
and to a queen and they live in a high
flag system with a queen at the top of
the chain they are the most sought after
prey for predators to hunt
7 the river coast these strange alien
life forms are called the river coast
and they are a sentient species which
like humans were hunted by the super
predators on the game preserved planet
the river ghosts are humanoid in
appearance but are shrouded in pale
insect-like exoskeletons that cover most
of almost all of their bodies while they
have recesses comparable to human eye
sockets at the front of their head they
do not appear to have or possess any
visible eyes while a sensory organ
covered by a movable flap of bone is
located in the center of their forehead
their teeth extend forwards from their
mouth on plates of bones leaving a
considerable gap to their mouths they
have a greatly elongated talons on their
hands and strange bony almost wing-like
protrusions on their back
they are also very fast and that is why
they are on the preserved planet hunted
by the super predators
number eight the hellhounds also known
as the predator dogs they are an
aggressive dog dog-like extraterrestrial
species used by the super predators
as hunting tools despite being called
dogs or hounds hellhounds are they
appear to be therapists rather than dogs
which are primitive reptilian looking
ancestor to mammals and even reptiles
they have scales and have an almost
ankylosaurus-like appearance but look
vaguely canine at the same time they
have a set of horns and or tusks on
their head that jut out forwards and
they are truly terrifying and are highly
resistant to bullet fire with massive
amounts of lead needed to be pumped into
them to take one down
number nine or ninthly the predator
hounds these are strange yet so familiar
creatures altogether it is a non-sapient
species used by the upgrade predator to
hunt and chase down and kill prey the
predator hounds are chimeric canines
created through hybridization techniques
similar to once used to augment their
master with the base genome being an
unspecified extraterrestrial hound
species and other species put in
together the yajja dna is among an
addition of genomes involved in their
creation
and it is seen through their jarring
resemblance to the race donor in
question most notable being their tan
height green blood and dreadlocks on
their heads
although the hounds lack mandibles
and lastly the tech sec tech sects were
mechanical weapons artificial bugs
designed by the likeness of a xenomorph
they are roughly the size of a queen
perhaps two to three feet shorter and
bipedal with digital great automatons
and silvery white chassis
their ceramic skin is acid-proof and
resistant to other elements such as fire
and explosions oh yeah they were created
by an ai
a yellow visor acts as their eyes on the
robot
they are robots alien robots would say
they have clawed hands and feet and
along their spines are dorsal tube-like
appendages much like the one seen in the
xenomorphs and they are configurable and
can be weaponized although they lack
tails the tech sags are said to be equal
to the alien in terms of ferocity maybe
even superior in some ways with variable
weapons that can be installed on them
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well but most
of all smash the bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam